Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
thor love and thunder video they dropped the
new trailer i did a video for it but a lot of you
been asking about the cosmic entities that show up
in the trailer specifically like the most powerful
cosmic beings that you'll ever see in the mcu
multiverse so we'll break it down why they're
there and which ones there are because there
are a lot of brand new ones but we've actually
seen them referenced in the mcu before that's
right all these figures that you see in this room
here have shown up in the mcu before in some form
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the marvel videos
i'm also getting ready to do obi-wan kenobi
episode videos too starting later this week
but when jane foster's mighty thor crashes down
into the hall below you can see statues of a bunch
of the most powerful cosmic entities in the mcu
and the multiverse like i said all of them have
been featured or referenced in some way inside the
mcu movies before this but this is the first time
that we've seen a place that's referenced all of
them together at the same time like all the most
powerful beings in the difference between these
cosmic entities and beings like the celestials
who are incredibly powerful cosmic beings are that
most of the cosmic entities here are meant to be
the living aspect of pure ideas and concepts just
given physical form that's why there's only one
of them in the entire multiverse as opposed to
beings like the celestials which are incredibly
powerful but you have a different celestial host
for each universe like there's a different version
of ayrshim the judge for each universe so in this
hall we're talking about being so powerful that
they're meant to be more powerful than the mcu
gods that gorr has been going around and killing
during this movie and even though they are meant
to be like the top tier of power in the mcu you
can still kill cosmic entities it just requires
really special circumstances or really special
power-ups like since doctor strange two multiverse
of madness we've been talking about them teasing
time runs out in the big lead up to secret wars
during that storyline the big difference is that
it was the beyonders who were responsible for
the incursions and because they're these super
powerful extra dimensional beings they have
enough power to kill the living tribunal that's
how powerful you'd have to be to kill cosmic
entities like this but you can kill them the
only being who's more powerful than all these
cosmic entities would be like the one above all
the one true god of the multiverse but he's so op
he's probably never gonna get used in a real way
during a big marvel movie story just because he
kind of breaks any story that he ever enters into
like how do you have stakes when you have
a being that can literally do anything
in this scene there are supposed to be at
least six figures behind jane foster's thor
there might be more statues of other cosmic
entities in front of her out of frame that
we just can't see yet but the ones that we can
see just going around the room starting in the
upper right hand corner start with the living
tribunal we just saw the real version of the
living tribunal during doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness when america chavez opens the portal
they go crashing through all the universes one of
the universes they crash through just happens to
have the living tribunal's heads getting ready
to judge something or someone i've already done
a billion videos about the living tribunal of the
mcu so i'll post a link to my full doctor strange
2 breakdown if you want to learn more specifically
about that cosmic entity they were going to use it
during avengers infinity war during the big thanos
battle on titan but wound up having to delete it
so i talked about that during the full breakdown
video behind it on the right a lot of you have
asked if this is meant to be a version of the
watcher uatu it's possible but the watchers aren't
meant to be cosmic concepts they're just a race of
highly advanced beings that are even more powerful
than most of the mcu gods they're like highly
evolved cosmic beings on par with the celestials
oh man anyway before i was so rudely interrupted
at that time i was a federal express man
the trailer's a little too low-res and blurry
so we can't zoom in and hands enough to confirm
but his cape that he's wearing isn't exactly
the same as the watchers from guardians of
the galaxy 2 movie in his head isn't quite
as big relative to the rest of his body as
those ones were but what they might be doing
is just bringing the animated version of uatu
from what if into live action the way that they
did with captain carter during doctor strange too
it was a different version of captain carter but
it's the same idea like you take a character that
they debuted in animation and do a version
in live action because if you look at the
animated version of uatu he does look different
from the versions in guardians of the galaxy 2
and the version in the trailer looks closer to
the animated version of the watcher and it does
kind of look like he has the same high-backed
cape with a cape that goes up behind his head
you cannot compute the power of my will the only
difference between this version of the watcher
though in the version of the comics is that the
watchers are like an entire race of beings kind
of like the asgardians they're just super powerful
so the big difference in this hall is that most of
these cosmic entities only have one version for
the entire multiverse the watcher would be the
exception to that if this is the watcher like
there are many watchers out there all watching
different universes on the left of him all these
other heads of cosmic entities were featured
in the first guardians of the galaxy movie some of
you may have remembered this on the temple wall of
morag where the power stone was kept there was
a mural depicting four cosmic entities from the
infinity gauntlet saga big deep cuts from the
comics in that movie it was meant to be death
entropy eternity and infinity the skeletal head in
the upper left hand position here is most likely
the cosmic entity death and there's already been
a huge deep cut for her character with the thanos
and infinity saga they based the infinity saga
of movies avengers infinity war avengers end
game on the thanos infinity gauntlet storyline
and in that story he had vowed to win the love
and affection of the cosmic entity death by
snapping half the universe that was the whole
reason why he assembled the infinity gauntlet in
the comics the big joke though is that because she
is the cosmic entity representing the idea of
death in the entire multiverse all of reality
no amount of death was ever enough for her she
just wanted more and more death so no matter how
many people he killed she was never impressed
you will never get this you will never get this
chasing that high that he's never going to get the
image of the man directly behind her would either
be entropy or eternity it's a little bit different
from the depiction that we've seen in the comics
before it is a man but it could be either one
of those figures entropy's purpose is all about
destruction the drive pits him in this constant
struggle with eternity whose goal is creation
together they keep the cycles of
creation and destruction in balance
behind him the figure of the woman in the back
left is infinity infinity represents all space
in the universe infinity and eternity are in this
constant competition with death who attempts to
reduce life while infinity and eternity expand
life she's also meant to be the sister of eternity
eternity is also meant to be the living
representation of a universe so like there's
many versions of eternity the living embodiment
of the entire multiverse is called the cosmos
the hidden figure on the back right that
we can't see would be the other one either
eternity or entropy the reason why jane foster's
thor would be looking for this place specifically
is probably because it has some information or
power that will help them fight gorr the god
butcher and learn more about what's going on with
the necro sword and it might be another big deep
cut easter egg for the mcu version of omnipotence
city that's meant to be a nexus of gods that shows
up in the gorr storyline in the comics thor goes
there seeking more information about gorr and
the necro sword and just the gods in general
the backstory behind this omnipotence city is
that the first elder gods like you're talking
about cthulhu you're talking about cathode the
god of chaos which was referenced during doctor
strange two about four billion years ago they had
a god-tier version of avengers end game a big war
of the gods like the very first war of the gods at
the end of that they signed a truce and as part
of that truce they built this omnipotence city
meant to be a nexus for all of their knowledge
and all their power like a place of fellowship
where people could visit other lesser gods could
come visit and learn more about their existence
so if you thought that asgard was meant to be
this place of power like odin has a treasure vault
imagine like an even greater god-tier version of
that that holds all this knowledge all this power
some of what we see in the trailer with this
giant parliament of the gods in the movie kind
of seems like it's happening in the mcu version
of mount olympus but the movie is using it the
same way they used omnipotence city in the gorr
comics so this just seems like a side quest that
jane foster's thor has gone on trying to get more
information about how to fight gorr in the necro
sword a lot of you've also asked questions about
what's going on with the necro sword in the movie
and gorr the god butcher because it seems like the
power of the necro sword is like bleeding the life
force away from him turning him into a version of
emperor palpatine because during all these fight
scenes at the end of the trailer it seems like
the necro sword's power is just draining the force
out of everything in all of reality and that's why
there's no color like the only thing shining light
or color on their faces is the power coming off of
zeus's lightning bolt i think that's just part of
the necro sword's mcu powers like in addition
to him using it as a blunt force weapon like
stabbing them or cutting their heads off it also
drains their god tier life force their essence
for those of you that are also asking about
the new mjolnir powers thor's hammer there's
a scene where jane foster's thor and regular
thor are fighting zeus's men and they're all
going crazy in this giant parliament here when she
throws the hammer at them the hammer pieces all
seem like they break apart and attack all these
people separately then reform back to the normal
hammer so it's like in reforming the hammer has
also gained this area of effect physical attack
the reason the hammer came back together in the
first place i believe is mostly because when
hella broke the hammer physically she was not
able to break odin's enchantment and something
happens to make jane foster's thor worthy and
she just touches the hammer and that reforms
everything gives her the armor and gives her the
same power set as thor had in the earlier movies
a lot of you've also asked what's happening to
the regular version of thor after this movie
is he going to sacrifice himself what's going
to be happening with him during marvel phase 5
big secret wars arc taika wattidi says that even
though he doesn't know everything that marvel is
gonna do in the next five or six years no one has
told him about getting rid of the regular version
of thor so it sounds like chris hemsworth thor is
going to be sticking around long term and he'll
be here for this lead up to secret wars right now
just based on the themes of the trailer it seems
like he's going to becoming more cosmic like i
talk about rune king thor the more cosmic powerful
version of thor in the more earth-based problems
will be something that jane foster's lesser
version of thor winds up taking care of day to
day but when we get more information about what's
going on with the cosmic entities what's going
on with these different versions of thor and just
the movie in general with more trailers of course
i'll do more videos but if there's anything in the
trailer that you have more specific questions
about just write them below in the comments
my full obi-wan kenobi episode 1 and episode 2
videos will post this friday after they release
them and we're probably going to get a mandalorian
season 3 trailer in a couple other big star wars
trailers so of course i'll be doing videos for
all that stuff make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss those everyone
click here for my full thor love and thunder
trailer video and easter eggs and click here for
my brand new black panther 2 first look video
at namor thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!